hallo herzlich willkommen den renner
kochwelt heute gibt es mal wieder eine
richtig leckere suppe denn letztes mal
kam die suppe auch richtig gut an
und heute geht es ganz spezielle
türkische suppe bei uns zu hause gab's
frühjahr eigentlich jeden tag super
meiner mama team eine super gekocht
reist dazu und dann gab es eben noch ein
hauptgericht und einer meiner lieblings
suppen einer meiner lieblings türkischen
zucken muss jetzt sagen ist die
türkische linsensuppe und die mache ich
jetzt einfach etwas anders als meine
mama denn sie hat immer ziemlich wenig
gemüse drin
ich habe immer ein bisserl mehr gemüse
mit dabei und man muss dazu sagen das
ist jetzt kein standard rezept also die
hinten zugemacht wirklich jeder anders
die schmeckt auch in jeder familie
anders und das ist die version die wir
zu hause oder beziehungsweise die ich
bei mir zu hause macht und so schmeckt
sie uns eben am besten und ich zeige
euch jetzt einfach mal meine zutaten
ich habe hier 200 gramm lenton also
ungefähr so ein glas volk die gibt es ja
überall zu kaufen meine sind zwei zum
budget aber die kids wirklich überall
dann habe ich hier karotten zwiebeln und
kartoffeln und zwar jeweils etwa 150
gramm also gezählt das sind jetzt etwa
180 gramm
dann brauchen wir gleich noch
zitronensaft ich benutze wahrscheinlich
den saft einer zitrone
ich brauch zwischen eineinhalb bis zwei
liter wasser
dann brauche ich etwas tomatenmark
olivenöl und hier noch ein paar gewürze
ich hab s salz chili typen jahren hier
habe ich noch minze und etwas pfeffer
und das war es eigentlich auch schon
und dazu gibt es später bei uns einfach
ein bisschen fladenbrot und dann noch
ein haupt mir ist und ich stehe jetzt
einfach mit den mit dem gemüse und
schälen das jetzt einfach ganz kurz und
häckslern klein
die karotte sorgt in dem gericht
natürlich nicht nur für die toll für die
tolle geschmack sondern auch für die
schöne farbe denn ich mag es wenn meine
linden super erste orange ist unser geld
nicht hat halt auch optische gründe
glaub ich hab in unsere familie gar kein
linie gar keine karotten was dann drei
jahren und weiß es ihnen geschmeckt was
meine mutter gekocht hat wahrscheinlich
geheiratet und die kartoffeln sorgt
natürlich im gericht einfach für die
konsistenz dass die suppe eben nicht so
flüssig ist und einfach so ein bisschen
wenig ist dass sie gebunden wird durch
die kartoffelstärke ich finde es
vielleicht zu jeder mahlzeit die suppe
finde ich eigentlich auch als vorspeise
genau will das setting dann aufwändig
und aussteigen die wand so voll bei der
hauptspeise ich habe ich weiß aber ich
halte mir bzw drittel die kartoffeln
jetzt so ein bisschen
ich bin nämlich gleich zum schneiden
einfach mein schneidegerät aber ihr
könnt auch einfach so jetzt ganz grob
würfeln man einfach ganz kleine feine
würfel zuerst die zwiebeln
da kann jetzt einfach alles zusammen
rein
so sieht jetzt das gemüse aus also
richtig schön fein gewürfelt einfach
alles zusammen und jetzt welche man die
linsen noch waschen
das ist auch mal ganz wichtig meine mama
tj maxx an linsen muss man immer waschen
deswegen gebe ich sehr einfach in
sondern sie und die folgende auch nicht
und die falle gar nicht durch genau und
jetzt gehe ich sie kurz unter heißem
wasser abwaschen
jetzt gebe ich die linsen einfach in
einen großen topf nimmt auch auf jeden
fall einen topf sei groß genug ist und
dann gebe ich da das gemüse draus katzen
und jetzt fühle ich das ganze mit dem
wasser auf aber ich nehme es noch nicht
das komplette wasser sondern erstmal nur
eineinhalb liter und später werden wir
einfach sehen ob ich noch ein bisschen
mehr oder weniger brauche es ruhig jetzt
kurz durch damit der einfache tricks am
topfboden klebt und dann gehe ich dann
deckel drauf ich nehme jetzt einfach die
kosten damit es später nicht überkocht
wenn ich jetzt nämlich einen topfdeckel
drauf gibt bei linsen passiert das ganz
auf das sie zum beispiel ein bisserl auf
schäume und dann kurz über deswegen
nehme ich die nummer da passiert nichts
und jetzt schalte ich den herd ein auf
höchste stufe lass es aufkochen und dann
las ich so lange kochen bis die
kartoffeln einfach weich sind
es dauert ungefähr zwanzig minuten meine
suppe ist jetzt durch gekauften jetzt
muss ich sie nach syrien
botta sie dann ist ja richtig lecker aus
sally und der topf ist geschrumpft
wie hast du das mit ja und ein kleines
missgeschick passiert ist ja echt
aufpassen laptop stuck nicht und dort
eine schuld und zwar wenn der topf auf
dem herd steht dann muss halt immer
wieder wasser nachgießen und vor allen
dingen bisher rühren damit einfach
nichts anbrennt und bei mir ist einmal
passiert sei stelle tot oder
angebranntes dinge habe ich jetzt die
super schnell umgefüllt damit am
geschmack nicht verändert jetzt muss
durch pürieren und zwar keine schuld
weil du soviel geredet hat
einmal kurz durch püriert und ich gebe
da jetzt aber noch ein bisschen wasser
mit rein denn die suppe ist mir jetzt zu
dick
das sieht man jetzt auch hier ziemlich
dicke suppe viel wasser verdunstet ich
gebe jetzt ein bissel wasser rein muss
es aber natürlich minuten kochen lassen
aber da passiert dieses mal auch damit
dass nichts passiert ich werde jetzt
aber schon mal die suppe abschmecken und
zwar kommt da ganz viele zitronensaft
rein das ist doch echt wichtig denn die
suppe muss ein bisschen eine säure haben
wenn man übrigens so eine suppe in der
türkei im restaurant es dann gibt es
auch immer zitrone mehr dazu n stress
morath
er war so viel wie ihr wollt erstmal nur
die hälfte und dann kann man immer noch
abstimmen abschmecken und vor allen
dingen kann einfach jeder selber so viel
zitrone in seinen teller geben wie er
möchte
und jetzt wird sich einfach noch mit
meinen gewürzen also mit salz pfeffer
salz nehme ich jetzt einfach so ein
teelöffel dann frischen pfeffer für den
geschmack dann noch etwas chili bei mir
kommt immer bissle mehr rein
wer übrigens zu hause oder kenwood hat
man die super übrigens super in dieser
kenwood machen denn das ganze einfach
nicht gehabt das problem hat ich habs
jetzt natürlich hier im topf gemacht für
euch damit ihr wisst es auf topfit aber
normalerweise macht man die einfach
hinter kennen und dann hört sie ständig
und da verdammt auch nicht so viel
wasser weil der deckel immer drauf ist
und da passiert die minze gebe ich jetzt
netz mit ihnen die suppe denn die minze
kommt gleich obendrauf
ich brauche es aber noch viel wasser
fast jedem tier kurz kochen aber ich
stelle es kurz auf die andere herdplatte
denn jetzt kommt das besondere dieser
linsensuppe und zwar habe ich ja noch
olivenöl und tomatenmark da und es wird
jetzt einfach in einen topf erhitzt
unsere ein bisschen angebraten und es
kommt dann später einfach somit in den
teller rein und es ist so das besondere
was eben dieses türkische teams ausmacht
hat mit wem kommuniziert zwei esslöffel
olivenöl in die pfanne
speziell mit eintopf es gibt sie auf den
hübschen krieger so kurz was an brüsten
und brahms dieses brach aroma
das macht man ja auch eher an tesla für
tomatenmark wobei ich da mit butter und
paprikapulver mache und jetzt halt mit
olivenöl und tomatenmark und es scheint
dass es heiß werden
so und jetzt kann es hier noch die
pfefferminze mit hier rein geben mit
zudem mit zum tomatenmark hat so ein
bisschen und das frühere ich noch kurz
das recht hat echt gut getrocknete mensa
ist schon lecker und so sieht es jetzt
aus und es gebe ich jetzt einfach mit
zur suppe und damit einfach eingerührt
und dann müsste die super einfach nur
noch abschmecken und können sie dann
direkt serviert
ich würde jetzt persönlich noch ein
bisschen zitrone mit dazugeben mein mann
max er nicht so zitronig deswegen lege
ich einfach eine zitronenscheibe mit
dazu und gibt es jetzt hier in die
hübschen tassen rein
das ist so richtig so etwas erinnert
mich irgendwie an zu hause jeder kind
ist und wer möchte kann noch bis oben
drauf es sieht nicht nur schön aus oder
schmeckt auch richtig gut
und dazu gibt es übrigens wege sagt
dieses fladenbrot dass ich jetzt nun
zwar ein gekauftes fladenbrot aber ich
habe auch schon mal ein peter selber
gemacht also ein typisches plagen pro
können so zum beispiel auch selber
machen und ist dann einfach so serien
und der murat kriegt natürlich auch ein
teller zum probieren und farbe ich
richtig schön hat auch karotte
es gibt ja
ein großer kritiker
vielleicht müssten sie auch einfach ein
bisschen anbrennen lassen und dann
entwickelt sich das volle aroma
ja klar aber ich mache mir noch trikot
das rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auch
sallys - blog.de